groupe l'est républicain merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur olivier
ferrand ministre de la solidarité de la
santé monsieur le ministre la situation
épidémique de notre pays est inquiétante
l'augmentation de la circulation du
virus est désormais exponentielle et
nous sommes dans la deuxième vague et
nous nous apprêtons à vivre
malheureusement le remake de la
précédente
la première vague a été celle de
l'improvisation ni masque ni j'allais
drôle hic ni blouse pénurie de
médicaments injonctions contradictoires
à répétition du gouvernement d' inutile
le port du masque est devenu obligatoire
sous peine de sanctions les faux pas et
le pilotage à vue des pouvoirs publics
se sont succédé au discours
contradictoires du gouvernement et de
l'exécutif se sont malheureusement mail
et ceux tout aussi contradictoires des
scientifiques ébloui pour certains par
les feux de la rampe
la seconde vague et celle de
l'impréparation elle avait pourtant été
annoncé dès le mois de juillet par le
conseil scientifique et le professeur
jean françois delfraissy l'avait dit et
répété il le dit lui même il n'a pas été
écouté par ailleurs nous apprenons
monsieur le ministre par la presse que
le général lizurey missionné par le
premier ministre en avril dernier a
proposé 21 une solution pour mieux gérer
la crise sanitaire le minimum aurait été
d'en informer le parlement ou au moins
la commission denquête ce qui n'a pas
été le cas
le répit laissé par le virus cet été
aurait dû être mis à profit pour mieux
nous préparer
il n'en a rien été on a laissé les
français se faire traiter en masse pour
faire du chiffre
sans stratégie ce qui a embelli c'est le
système avec des résultats pour les
patients qui parfois mettait plus d'une
semaine arriver si l'on a beaucoup parlé
des brigades sanitaire peu les ont vus
pourquoi ne pas avoir mis à profit ce
mois d'été monsieur le ministre pour
préparer l'ouverture de lits de
réanimation supplémentaires vous en avez
annoncé 12000 le 27 août dernier
il y en a que 5 milles 7 dont 5000
opérationnel pourquoi ne pas avoir cet
été formé
votre vision des aides soignants des
infirmiers des internes pour venir en
renfort au service de réanimation en
tant que de besoin
ma question monsieur le ministre est
simple espérez vous un jour sortir la
france de cette crise pour vous répondre
aux parents les communistes des
solidarités de la santé monsieur le
président millions j'ai d'abord vous
répondre sur l'état de préparation où
vous êtes à cet été monsieur c'est un
temps millions il ya plusieurs milliers
de soignants qui ont été formés par le
gouvernement ni par vous d'ailleurs mais
par les hôpitaux par les facultés par
les régions déterminante déterminante
qui ont augmenté les capacités de
formation express de plusieurs milliers
de soignants pour qu'ils puissent venir
participer aux soins dans les services
de réanimation cet été 15 % de lits de
réanimation supplémentaires sont restés
armée équipée ouvert de façon pérenne
dans notre pays 15% pour considérer que
c'est peu en trois mois pour les
hôpitaux qu'on fait cet effort je peux
vous garantir que c'est beaucoup c'est
le sénateur millions vos chiffres datent
5700 lit c'était avant-hier
hier nous étions assis 1400 lits et
bientôt nous allons monter à 7500 lits
pourquoi nous mentons progressivement
monsieur le sénateur parce que si nous
des programmes y ont tous les soins d'un
coup évidemment on montrait tout de
suite a dit miller onze mille lits mais
un celi ne serait pas aujourd'hui
utilisé par des malades covin et 2 on
retarde leur aide et soins utiles pour
les français et vous me poseriez a
raison cette fois ci la question de
savoir pourquoi est ce qu'on ne souhaite
pas les français avec des lits vides
donc cette montée en gamme se fait de
façon progressive monsieur le sénateur
on n'a pas testé à vide un million neuf
cent mille tests sont réalisés par
semaine dans notre pays avec un taux de
positivité des tests plus de 17%
croyez-moi on teste pas à vide et je me
souviens de débat ici on me demandait
pourquoi est ce qu'on ne testez pas en
population asymptomatiques tous azimuts
par ailleurs 100 mille appels sont
passés par jour par les ars et
l'assurance maladie auprès des personnes
qui sont mises à l'abri en raison du co
lead et après monsieur le sénateur quand
elles à savoir qui avait raison qu'ils
avaient tort sur la deuxième vague
je laisse les français qui regardent
public sénat cherchez la dernière fois
que j'étais en train de répondre à ce
micro dans cet hémicycle c'était il ya
quelques jours froids que l'une des
dernières interventions j'avais fait
monsieur le rapporteur bassin souviens
parce qu'il était d'accord avec moi
c'était pour demander aux sénateurs de
droite et de gauche
d'abord la responsabilité de ne pas
voter un amendement déposé par tous les
groupes de sénateur
empêcher le gouvernement de fermer des
établissements recevant du public et
autorisant donc de fait c'était il ya
quelques jours la réouverture des
discothèques à marseille des restaurants
à lyon des bars à saint-etienne à telle
enseigne qu une deuxième délibération a
été demandée dans l'urgence par les
sénateurs voyant l'erreur qui a été
commise donc s'il vous plaît pas de sens
[Musique]